well I dug up this quote that you have
here and it's from an interview that you
did with Latino la com okay and you said
I enjoy working with Latinos it's like
being at a family reunion there's lots
of dancing lots of laughter and good
food we Latinos don't get an opportunity
to work all that much so when we do have
this opportunity we're very grateful and
we have a party yes do you think that
demand is now increasing though you say
in the past you haven't had the
opportunity maybe to work as much as a
group but you think that's changing and
how do you think you can change it well
yes it's true what I said in that quote
the projects that I've worked on
resurrection Boulevard predominantly
Latino cast behind the scenes that was
also predominantly Latino crew executive
producers Latino and walk out also
predominantly Latino cast I don't know
what it is it really hate we just we
just want to have a good time we really
enjoy each other's company we're
dramatic we're funny we we just love
gossip you know that's why the deadly
novellas are so popular we just love
gossip we love talking about people and
we love sharing information and knowing
each other's business and so when you
put so many of us together we were just
so happy to a be working and and we also
have so much in common you know and I
think it really is like a family reunion
because we could possibly be cousins
going up we Latinos populate we possibly
could be related so we just take that
into account and we're all like cousins
and so walk out was a great experience
I'm friends with the majority of that
entire cast like on a personal level
Michael Pena is one
them who was on that show and
resurrection Boulevard Nicholas Gonzalez
so these guys are my friends I see them
on a daily basis we hug we catch up we
really are and so Mission Park was no
different emission bark was also shot in
Texas and but you know the top guys were
Latino so we sort of said we gotta spice
up this production and and have a good
time the truth is we're here we're
making a movie why wouldn't we have a
good time why would we be bitter and
angry and screaming and yelling and all
that I think that filmmakers like Brian
and myself are definitely generating
more work with Latinos in front and
behind the camera and I'd love to see
more of them because like I said we just
have such a great time we really love
each other we hate each other and we
love to dance and we love to eat and it
is one big party really so I think that
the American audience and also the
American non-latino actors producers are
going to really have a good time with us
you